so we had to get joe on the show
especially since my children
love this man because they can't get
enough holy moly and we will discuss a
little bit of that too
yeah with joe tessitore here on the rich
eisen show how are you joe
i'm doing well rich i'm still trying to
uh you know gather what took place
saturday night
wildly unexpected let me tell you joe i
am doing well man it's been a long time
since you and i
spoke um and uh when i saw that i had to
reach out to you
uh and get you on here because the
reaction um
is appropriate the reaction that so many
people had just seeing and
and hearing it in your voice um
it was was just amazing uh what walk me
through this
uh joe seeing your your son out there
and then watching him in a
in a big moment in this game i mean
listen it's so
abnormal it just is obviously you know
we've been really blessed that
that john uh became the athlete he
became and worked very very hard to be
recruited and end up
you know earning a scholarship to play
football bc you know
what kind of uh married up in terms of
his football life and my football life
is i went off to do monday night
football
and i said well this is great i can just
i can just watch john on saturdays in
between production meetings and whatnot
i never have to have that pressure
of having to worry about you know even
bc
at a time where they were maybe even
being good enough to be playing on abc
against number one team in the country
or that being my assignment
and don't you know here i am now up on
that game so it put me in a spot it
happened about a month ago they were
playing on abc against north carolina
and i really had to pause and ask how do
i handle this assignment
and uh in that game coach hathaway sent
him out
in the shotgun down two on an extra
point potentially
going for a conversion so in that split
second i had to say
oh my god i'm rich what do i say what do
i do and it was you know
shotgun testatory but thankfully he
counted numbers they waved them in they
kicked the extra point he didn't put me
in that spot
and then this weekend here we are and
it's at clemson it's the best team in
the country and all of a sudden bc's got
things going and now they've got some
momentum and
he comes out and he's going to be the
holder for the extra point and he pulls
that thing off
so it was i think what hit us the most
most is the reaction because it was
genuine it was authentic
and having gone through the experience
of him being in the shotgun against
north carolina i knew
just say tessa tour just play it
straight just try to control yourself
just sit there and call the game the way
you normally would um
but now you can breathe and you can
reflect and you realize what happened
and and you know and and you uh having
way before you know you called a game
for espn
uh you know about sportscasting you've
done many highlights in your day
as well you know that sometimes
something great happens and the
highlight isn't
that significant when it is in
retrospect because
uh it doesn't lead to a point it doesn't
lead to something but your son's play
led to something significant just later
on which made it even that much more
special of a play forget about the
father-son relationship right
that had to be pretty cool for you to
call that as well that it led to
a pretty nifty touchdown for boston
college as well just mere
yeah because it was definitely the high
water mark of the game in terms of
holy cow the number one team in the
country is down 18. he pulls that off it
was an amazing momentum
surge and on the very next play they got
him on their heels the heads are
spinning and they pull off
cj lewis there's another local
connecticut kids you grew up five
minutes away from john they grew up
playing youth sports and scrimmaging
against each other
um makes this amazing catch and they're
up 18 which i believe our graphics
people put in as the largest home
deficit a number one team in the country
has had since
1950 so it was definitely that moment
the oh wow moment but
rich really you know john and i spoke
last night and
i don't know if it's just because what's
been going on in our news
cycles as a country of what we end up
consuming in big time live events but it
doesn't feel like there's been much in
2020
where things are universally accepted
and that communal feeling that sports
gives you
of watching things on tv where the whole
country says that was good
i feel good about that something touched
me but saturday that definitely happened
with people and if we played just a
small role in that
of seeing that love and pride between
father and son then that makes us really
happy you did
joe tessitore here on the rich eyes and
show you definitely did play a role
in all that so uh hang on a second so
you knew
cj lewis like from youth as well you
knew the kid
who caught the touchdown now strangely
also three
nearly consecutive big plays that bc had
to get up by 18 the brandon sebastian
97-yard fumble return brandon's from
west haven connecticut played at
john's rival high school cheshire
academy he's a good friend of the family
they have a lot of friends in common
youth basketball youth football all the
kids playing against each other growing
up
cj's from hampden the next town over
from russell wallingford he's known cj
for years
and then basically came to wallingford
and went to show they played against
each other in high school they played
each other you know they're in youth
basketball
so the boys have known each other
forever and now they're college
teammates and they have those three
consecutive big plays to go up on
clemson
so this is the easiest board you've ever
had maybe in front of you calling a game
right you know
with the match-up numbers i said i don't
need you
you threw your spotter out of the booth
because i grew up with these kids they
they trick-or-treated at my house for
crying out loud
that is so cool and again that the
moment uh just let's just
spend another couple minutes on this
part of our conversation if you don't
mind
the when you saw your son after the game
uh you know can you share a little bit
of that conversation i know that we saw
that photograph of you
messed up john is super alpha it's not
super alpha and wired
a certain way so he was still hot like a
hornet coming out of the locker room
and uh we were one play away we couldn't
upset the number one team
and so you had to let that simmer down
for a little bit sure
and then uh i said uh are you aware
right now
that what happened on the field is going
mega viral that there
are espn push notifications and every
website in the world is just
touched by what happened and he's like
no i didn't realize that uh so by the
time they got to the bc
plane and he was with his phone for
about 25 minutes he texted me and just
said wow
but you know listen at that level it's
all about winning or losing for them
it's tough for them to
you know sit back and think like an
individual of what happened
uh but last night you know we had a long
talk and he realized how special it was
yeah and the photograph that we're
showing right here
uh is the photograph that was tweeted
out i think the body language actually
speaks to what you're saying about wire
differently there you are and that
perfectly manicured uh
uh or perfectly tailored jacket pointing
at him hand and pocket
and he's got a fist he's got a fist
balled up like he's like he's in a ufc
uh fight card right there it's like
you're weighing in
that's what it looks like right there
yes that's the intensity of the beaming
pride and emotion of the 49 year old dad
yes and the unbridled intensity of the
junior in college who just wants to beat
clemson's ass joe tessa tour here
on the rich eisen show let's talk a
little bit about clemson which did pull
out the win
and is now taking on notre dame without
trevor
lawrence um when you spoke to dabo
leading up to this game against boston
college and you saw
what happened on the field walk me
through the mood i guess
or what is going on with that team
without trevor lawrence due to covet 19.
joe well you know that's not i got to be
honest with you rich when you sit there
and you think about
life without trevor lawrence you prince
she's the face of the sport he's the
you know undoubted number one nfl draft
pick to come and generationally i really
think we're talking about a player that
when we reflect on college football
history
you know he's going to be one of those
rare guys who fits into two
boxes that we don't often think of and
that is we have the great all-time
college players when you say college
quarterback be it a
you know a doug foodie of vince young a
tim
tebow a johnny manziel when you say
college quarterback those
iconic kind of guys are all-time great
college guys
then we have the guys who you think
about the greats that are the no-brainer
blue ship prospect you can see it coming
a mile away the number one pick kind of
guys whether it's an
elway or a patent or an andrew luck
in trevor you have both you have the guy
that's probably going to leave with one
of the greatest resumes
and those magical iconic moments that
speak to college football
as well as being the guy that since he
halfway through his freshman year we all
sat back that um i'm sorry when is he
turning pro when will that be are we
still putting a clock on this
so he's he's that special but
dj who we anger is not the issue rich
because that kid played great on
saturday
and he's a monster he's 250 pounds he's
the number one pocket pass recruit
coming out
he can throw it through a brick wall
he's physical
you know i've heard a lot of people
trying to make comparables this weekend
as to who he is some people said
well he's got the pure arm talent
strength of jamarcus russell don't think
about the pro version of russell just
think about the raw product
he's got a lot of dante culpepper in him
he's not the issue
i'm telling you i know trevor lawrence
isn't playing but pj's gonna be fine
that kid athletically can do it
i think one of the issues with them is
they're missing some pieces defensively
they're dealing with injuries
defensively
and in that first half the other day
against dc you saw what a pretty
talented speedy
bc offense was able to do against them
so james scoussi is out at middle
linebacker
for clemson they didn't have tyler davis
they're starting defensive tackle they
didn't have mike jones who plays that
hybrid nickel
outside linebacker position they need to
be at health against notre dame notre
dame's going to try to bully them a bit
and try to control that game and i think
it's going to be a fascinating showdown
did you get any sense of the storyline
that's going on in the nfl that trevor
lawrence would consider staying put
because he wants to avoid the jets who
have a nice pole position on his nose
not at all rich we had a really long
visit with trevor on wednesday prior to
the news of the covet positive test
um i think trevor and i know that one
quote he gave last week rich gave people
a headline that they could write of oh
maybe who knows
and i said to trevor i go are you just
saying the obvious that in any aspect of
life
you never know he said yes very much so
you i never want to say something 100
because that's not how life works you
never know what's going to happen but
every expectation and everything is on
course for him to be the number one pick
you can put presumptive in quotes
so uh before i let you go joe uh to
maintain my best dad ever status
um that i have here despite it being
considerably threatened by you uh i do
have to ask you about
one of my children's favorite shows in
holy moly um so i can go home and tell
them i asked you
when do we see more of this do we get to
see more of this because i know it might
be very
we are going to see more of it please we
are and we're enrolled about that
you know i know rob riggle's a friend of
your show and you know
rob just i think the world of him i
think he's so talented
we were so blessed with what we've been
able to do the past couple years but yes
you will see more put the plank and
volcano
you will even see more of your anus
right guys and you will see that um we
will be back for another season on abc
we're excited fantastic um we had
so much fun with the show my man i'm
thrilled that you're kids
do you ever get the chance when we're
out there filming bring them up to the
center
golf out there joe again i i may need
again your help to restore myself best
dad ever i will
and we'll take you up on that you know
god willing we can all do that soon
enough
um i'll tell you love is not the word
the volcano um may
make us laugh as a family hardest like
together we have had
we have had like gut busting laughs
watching that in holy moly
or you know obviously the the uh the the
port-a-potty doors
opening up oh yeah hitting people too i
believe
oh my gosh i'm telling you and again the
thing i i i i gush over the show because
not only is it just it's so great for
the whole family
is that i'll walk you through it i just
love just the whacked out
um scene you know with everybody going
crazy in those
holes being just uh played up in in a
very big fashion
uh i i i you got to love john lovitz
coming out with uh with an eye patch
and hitting some shots sometimes too
patches
just i love all of that wriggle's
hilarious and then
and then there's you joe you and and we
call it
here on the show a little shot of tessa
tour which we almost named our fantasy
team name because that's what i said
and we have actually a graphic we have
up on the screen it's you in a shot
glass your face you you're just
it's you and and just you are you're
having fun you're playing it up you're
camping it up
but it seems that you're genuinely
laughing like you can't hold it in
oh my all we did listen ask rob
we have it's listen it's best in show
lisa bromance with a little bit of borax
comedy documentaries
so when we get on that set they just
start rolling
and they don't stop and we don't stop
we just go and go and go until like
we're lacking
oxygen to our brain at about four in the
morning and that's about ninety percent
of what makes abc is what they film from
about two in the morning till five in
the morning
when the two of us are delirious but we
cannot get enough of it
and once again you know with what you
and i have done for most of our careers
you're sitting there i'm sitting on
monday night football i'm doing an abc
college football game and i'm calling a
championship fight
where we've got to be so dialed in and
so wired and
take one misstep twitter blows up forget
all that
just laugh just enjoy steve gutenberg
losing his mind
and wanting to climb over the set to
fight a diver and a hot dog
like like we don't care we laugh our
asses off and we cannot get enough
we have people writing mechanical gopher
grips i'm broadcasting on abc somebody
on a mechanical gopher think about this
by the way this is not some mad lib
you're making up these are all actual
facts yeah is it including if not
this actually happens at one point i
think you you spotted zac
efron in a hoodie in the crowd right
right josh
showed up that's right it just shows up
he loves the show shows up he's rooting
on one of his buddies who was a
contestant
just to know i mean these guys are
tailgating
they're tailgating for holy moly they're
having the time of their lives
we cannot laugh more than when we are on
that set
we love it regal and i can't get enough
of it it's so great
gutenberg bit with the kid who's
actually a diver
and then everyone else just belly flops
and they get nines
it's the greatest thing ever but
gutenberg losing his
absolute mind loses his body i mean
seriously
gregory gaines is like it's awesome
i mean you gotta hang out in the
trailers for this show i mean behind the
scenes is
crazy that's what i like about it i love
the fact that america
has embraced now for two years the pure
absurdity of it
it's it's great so it's more is coming
then right
when when yes when do we get more yes no
there will yes
we will be on abc in uh in 2021 we're
ready to rock and roll fantastic so
look forward to it somewhere late you
know mid to late spring you will have
holy moly back rocking a long time
we're being told i cannot wait and i
appreciate that invite i appreciate you
calling up
and uh and and taking the invite to
appear here and
congrats on that moment man just great
just great
thank you so much nice to share some
time with you fantastic right back at
you that's joe tessa tour thanks for the
call
joe tess right here on the rich eisen
show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here